Britain has long prided itself in
Fielding a force that others seek to
follow
a reference Army that Decades of cuts
have shrunk its size and strength even
as the threats grow
Now sources have revealed a senior U.S
general told the defense secretary
pictured here with his troops that the
British army is no longer regarded as a
top-level or tier one fighting force
it's a sorry Slide the service hopes to
fix but insiders say it needs more cash
from the UK's wartime prime minister in
the wake of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
a defense Source speaking anonymously
said about the Army it's an entire
service unable to protect the UK and our
allies for a decade defense is the thing
you do when you've done everything else
but we now live in a time where we need
a government that puts defense first so
that the country can be defended and
then also worry about its health is
education and its bottles
Ukraine Bears the scars of a country
that wasn't able to deter an invasion
like the town of boredianka defense
sources say the war here should be a
huge wake-up call for most western
allies to get serious about their own
defenses something that hasn't really
happened since the Cold War as things
stand for the UK its military would run
out of ammunition in just a few days if
called upon to fight and it lacks the
ability to protect British Skies from
the level of missile strikes that
Ukraine's enduring
Rishi sunak was Keen to be seen in
Ukraine after taking office pledging
more weapons for its defenses
that speeding up the rearming of his own
military didn't even make it onto the
list of his top priorities
Vladimir Putin's full-scale War has
prompted well over half of NATO's 30
member states to unveil new plans to
grow their Armed Forces
this includes Germany which will
allocate an extra 100 billion euros and
France which will lift defense spending
by 40 percent in the coming years
by contrast Mr sunac has made no new
pledges though he is refreshing a review
of defense policy which could lead to
more money
a government spokesperson said the prime
minister is clear that we have to do
everything necessary to protect our
people which is why the UK has the
largest defense budget in Europe and in
2020 we made the biggest investment in
the UK defense industry since the Cold
War
people weren't convinced in this
Garrison town in Yorkshire where Mr
sunac is also the local MP there's been
too many cutbacks in the forces
altogether so I don't agree with this
I like I like Rishi but he's wrong on
that if we we lose the Army we lose
everything that's been built around the
Army the the locals will suffer
others are happy to leave military
spending as it is but if the UK wants to
keep parading on the world stage it
might be time for a change of tune